[music]
>> the talk I've given.
If the label shows your intent to wear
it.
And in the talk, I've discussed in
detail
that for example,
if you get an MBBS degree
or MD degree,
you put a doctor in front of your name.
Why?
Why, brother Imam?
Because it's one of the good profession.
Yes. Because you think it's a good
profession and you're proud to be a
doctor, so you put doctor
in front of your name.
Correct?
We had the previously the cross. Now
there were different symbols for a
doctor. You also put a cross on your car
so that you're proud to be a doctor.
So if you're proud to be a Muslim,
this is the label.
If you're not proud to be a Muslim,
that's a different question.
That's the reason the beard comes.
And the beard helps you to recognize.
As Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Anam,
chapter number six.
It says, "Wa idhā jā'aka alladhīna
yu'minūna bi'āyātinā faqul salāmun
ʿalaykum." That when you meet the people
who believe in our signs, say,
"As-salamu alaykum."
Now, imagine how will I come to know the
person is clean-shaved. How will I
recognize him that he's a Muslim or not
Muslim?
How will I do salam to him?
I would like to narrate a small incident
to you.
That once
there was a young boy
was a hawker,
was a fruit seller,
and he was selling fruits.
So, elderly man
comes,
clean-shaven,
good Muslim,
used to pray five times a day,
used to fast in the month of Ramadan,
used to pay zakat, had gone for Hajj.
When he goes to buy the fruit,
he tells the young boy,
"Why didn't you wish me salams?"
So, the young boy tells him,
"Uncle,
I thought
you were a Hindu."
That means he's telling him that I
thought you were a mushrik.
A person who does idol worship.
Now, I'm asking you a question. That if
someone calls you an idol worshiper,
is there a bigger abuse than that?
Yes.
Is there any bigger abuse than that?
Who's to blame? The young boy?
Who's to blame?
Elderly person.
When you wish salam,
and he wishes back to you,
it's obligatory for every Muslim
fighting in the prophet said.
Salam, wish back walaykumsalam,
sneezing,
alhamdulillah, giving reply
yarhamukallah, visiting the sick,
following the pair,
the funeral pair.
So, how will you get the reward?
Especially in Islamic speech for a day.
It's very important that you have
Allah's help. And if it's a commandment,
you have to keep its appearance. Most
important according to me is the beard.
The final day is
quite long. So even those who don't
have,
yet 1 month is left. In 1 month,
mashallah, almost all can have at least
1 fist, inshallah.
Almost all I can say is everyone because
some people have a fast growth.
Point number two.
It is preferable to wear a cap which is
clean or cover your head.
Again, the same logic. If the label
shows your intent, wear it.
And I'm very clear that
covering your head is not a further in
Islam. The difference of opinion between
scholars whether the covering the head
is sunnah or not. According to Sheikh
Nasiruddin Albani, covering the head is
sunnah. He goes to the extent of saying
that if
the rawi, the narrators did not cover
the head, we did not take the hadith
from them also.
So covering the head is not further at
all.
Some scholars say it is mubah, optional.
Some scholars say it is sunnah. The
difference of opinion, let's not get
into the fit.
Difference of opinion.
But
my argument is if the label shows your
intent, wear it.
If you only keep a beard,
there are 80% chances you can come to
know from the beard whether he's a
Muslim or a non-Muslim. Because even
non-Muslims keep a beard,
but some non-Muslims with a beard will
have a mustache or like that.
Or Rajput or whatever.
So you can come to know he's not a
Muslim. Or he may have a turban along
with it. You may come to know that he's
not a Muslim. Or the way he keeps the
beard.
So whenever you see a man with a beard,
80% time you can decipher whether he's a
Muslim or not. So, if you tell he's a
Muslim, and the chances you'll be right
is 80%.
Now, when you see a Muslim
sporting a beard
and wearing a cap,
the chances you'll be correct is
99%.
Non-Muslims wear cap.
But, you can pick out what type of cap
hat
what it is.
So, if you see a human being
who's sporting a beard,
some people have the French beard.
That's not
Beard means proper beard.
French beard only coming here. Fine, if
your growth
doesn't permit it to grow anywhere else,
then no problem.
Like some of the communities have only
coming here, but alhamdulillah, it's
known
that certain types of people have only
here. It's a typical beard. But, those
who have got good
growth and yet they keep
only a French cut,
it will not be very helpful in
identifying to a great extent.
So, best is to keep a proper Islamic
beard and cover your head.
The chances that people
will
by mistake
think you're a non-Muslim is negligible.
Very negligible.
So, if the label shows your intent,
you wear it.
I'm very clear that covering the head
is not fard in Islam.
It is sunnah.
Some scholars say it is mubah.
Whatever it is, but surely it helps you
to identify and establish
that you are a Muslim. It can even be
covered in a ghutra like how would
Ibrahim be doing?
No problem. Some people
wear turban, also no problem.
It have to be a cap.
But, in this part of the world, where I
come from Indian subcontinent and many
other parts of the world,
the cap is there and from the cap you
can even come to know the culture and
the entities. A typical Turkish cap.
It's a typical Malay cap.
Any cap, as long as it's covering.
And the Hadith in Sahih Bukhari, volume
7 in the book of dress, that the prophet
wore a black turban.
It says the prophet
wore a white turban also. He also wore a
helmet. There are many Hadiths there.
The third very important point which is
not mentioned in the notes and you can
note it down.
It's not mentioned.
That trousers
should be above the ankle.
There are no less than 10
Sahih Hadiths
in the Kutub al-Sittah
which says
that trousers should be above the ankle.
In Sahih Bukhari,
there are no less than five Hadiths
in the book of dress, volume number
seven, Hadith number 5787, Hadith number
5788, Hadith number 5789, Hadith number
5790, and Hadith number 5791,
that the prophet Muhammad said
that anyone
who wears the trousers below the ankle
with pride, that part will burn in hell.
Out of five Hadiths, four Hadiths say
with pride, one Hadith says just
trousers below the ankle.
The one Hadith which does not include
the word pride,
says if anyone wears the trousers below
the ankle, or if it is a his lower
garment,
trails below the ankle,
that part will burn in hell. There are
Hadiths in Abu Dawud,
volume number four, in the book of
clothing,
Hadith number 4093,
which says
that
the trouser which goes below the ankle,
that part will burn in hell. It's also
repeated
in Sahih Muslim, book of clothing, and
this Hadith also repeats Sunan Abu Dawud
and the book of Tirmidhi, book of
clothing. There are no less than 10
Sahih Hadith
in the Kutub al-Sittah alone. Outside,
there may be more.
Which say
that
wearing trousers below the ankle,
that part will burn in hell.
And most of the Hadith say wearing
trousers below the ankle with pride, it
will burn in hell. There is no
difference of opinion in scholars
that if you wear the trousers below the
ankle with pride, it is
ghunah-e-kabirah.
Ghunah-e-kabirah means a major sin. It
is the major sin 55 in the list of Imam
al-Dhahabi when he narrates, when he
writes down
in his book al-Kaba'ir.
We'll discuss that later, inshallah.
That anyone who lets his trouser trail
below his ankle in pride,
it is a ghunah-e-kabirah.
Now, scholars differ
that if you let your trousers go below
the ankle,
whether it's a sin or not. With pride,
no difference of opinion, it is
ghunah-e-kabirah. It's a major sin.
But without pride, many scholars say
that it is a sin. Even without pride,
letting your trousers below the ankle is
a sin. Some scholars say no, it is not a
sin.
Let's not go into the
difference of opinion.
Okay, suppose you belong to that school
of thought
which says
that wearing trousers
below the ankle with pride is a major
sin,
but wearing trousers below the ankle
without pride is not a sin at all. If
you hypothetically happen to be in that
category,
I'm asking you the question, can any
human being say that pride will never
come in me.
The Prophet Muhammad S.A.W.
told Ibn Abbas, may Allah be pleased
with him,
when his trousers were going below, he
said, "Up." So, he put it on top.
He said, "Up." More on top. Up. More.
Till it went middle.
From the ankle to the knee to the middle
of the calf.
And
till that time
in his life, he never let it go below
that.
So, do you mean to say the argument
between the scholars is there? Let's not
go into the fiqh.
But, I say that even if you agree with
that school of thought which says that
trousers below the ankle without pride
is not a sin.
I cannot give guarantee of myself, at
least.
That I'm never proud of myself.
I don't have ego. Everyone has ego. Some
time or the other, you feel pride.
You feel proud.
And if that happens, not sin, major sin.
Allah says in the Quran
that if you take care of your major
sins, Allah will forgive your minor
sins. There are various hadiths of
Muhammad S.A.W. also on that. In such
cases, where it comes to kabair,
major sins,
better to be safe than to be sorry.
Better to be safe
than to be sorry. Let's not go into the
discussion whether it is haram or not. I
say
to all my students
and all the dais
that keep a beard,
the trousers should be above the ankle,
and wear the cap. But, naturally,
between all this,
most important is
the beard and the trouser above the
ankle.
If you don't cover the head, it's not a
sin at all.
If you feel you don't want to wear, no
problem.
You're not
going against any ruling of the Quran or
Sunnah.
Not against.
It's a Sunnah.
It's not a fard. If you don't do Sunnah,
no negative,
no positive. But, if you do it, you get
positive.
But, the beard and the trousers
are the most.
>> [music]
>> All the jewelry okay.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.